thanks very much for being on the
program
um let's start with Northern Ireland we
had Chrissy and Harris on the program a
little earlier and he said he's
optimistic that storm one is going to
get back up and running are you well I
hope he's right and I think he's right
to try and strike that tone we've had a
week where we've been reminded of what
can be achieved on the island of Ireland
what has historically been achieved when
political parties come together and work
together in the interests of the people
and I think he's right to lay down the
challenge to parties across Northern
Ireland that power sharing needs to get
back up and running very quickly who do
you blame for the impulse I I I think I
I don't want to get into the blame game
but I think that the biggest problem at
the moment is that the trust is not
there and when there have been these
moments ever since the Good Friday
agreement was negotiated and then signed
the the thing that has unlocked it has
been the emergence of an honest broker
usually the UK prime minister who has
been able to personally intervene in
order to bring people together and to
resolve the situation and the truth is
and this is you know not a blame game
point at all but the truth and the
reality is that since Theresa May sign
the deal with the dup that has been a
very difficult thing for all political
parties in Northern Ireland to accept
and there is a lot of work to do to
restore the trust to ensure that
political parties in Northern Ireland
all feel that there is an honest broker
in this situation and the person is
really important why isn't he an honest
breaker here I mean he managed to break
a deal with the EU well I I think the
conservative party's record an ability
to manage that process has been
tarnished we're talking about the
current prime minister sure I mean he
was a present feature of that government
all the way through particularly through
the Boris Johnson years he was a very
senior member of the government and I
think that is a problem but I think with
Goodwill with the involvement of the U.S
president which we've seen in the last
couple of weeks with the involvement of
the Irish t-shock and with the
involvement of the UK prime minister and
the will to make this work I think we
could see progress and I think it's
right that all political parties come
together and try Chris Eaton Harris also
said that if people lose faith in the
institutions of Northern Ireland which
will happen if someone doesn't get back
together that could lead to a rise in
Irish nationalism and he describes
that's the biggest threat to the union
is he right I think when people lose
faith in the system itself that you've
got a real problem on your hands and I I
don't want to downplay the seriousness
of what we're seeing in Northern Ireland
and on the island of Ireland but I also
think the is a problem across the whole
of the United Kingdom with people
increasingly feel that they don't have
faith in the political system to resolve
problems for them to make their lives
better and you know might just gently
say to Chris Heaton Harris that the
conservative government Bears some
responsibility for that that the actions
that we've seen particularly of the
Prime Minister the last two prime
ministers that we've had of Liz truss
and Boris Johnson have not gone any way
to restoring trust or confidence in
government and I think it is incumbent
on this Incarnation party what sort that
out what exactly are you talking about
are they that they're carrying out
brexit I mean no not at all look I I was
a remain campaigner I made no secret of
that and I I wanted us to stay in the
European Union but I accepted the result
as did most politicians at the time and
worked very hard alongside conservative
labor politicians
I think we've eroded trusted I think the
government has eroded trust in politics
I think particularly of what happened
during the pandemic where there was a
government that made the rules and then
broke the rules that lied about it and
laughed about it I think of the promises
that were made around brexit by the
Boris Johnson government in particular
which wish you soon at was a huge part
where promises were made that we would
have oven-ready brexit deals situation
in Northern Ireland would not be a
problem at all that it could all be
resolved and all political parties in
Northern Ireland feel very betrayed and
let down by that people electing
government there is work to do talking
about trust and politics I want to talk
about the s p as well because we have
seen the situation where Colin Beatty
resigning as SNP Treasurer after he was
arrested as part of the police
investigation into the party finances
how damaging is this well I think the
biggest damage is what it's done to the
people of Scotland because at the moment
what they've got is a failing government
at Westminster and a failing government
at holyrood if you look at what is
happening in Scotland at the moment I
think the things that I would be most
concerned about are the record waiting
times for a e the rising homelessness
the record number of drug deaths all
things that are going untackled because
they've got two failing jobs that are
mad in controversy do you think there's
a problem that the new first minister is
seen as a continuity candidate well
to me on that the SMP itself thinks so
his uh Challenger in the leadership
contest herself believed that he was one
of the most failing ministers in
government and that his record spoke for
himself
I think the bigger problem actually is
that the SMP doesn't seem to be able to
pull itself out of this and focus on the
country and the interests of the people
in the country in front of them instead
we've had this endless Merry-Go-Round of
accusations and recriminations it's
murky there have been a number of police
arrests the Mad in Scandal and there
seems to be no end in sight in the
meantime people are wondering if the
future that is on offer for their kids
is going to be anywhere like the future
that they had envisaged and they deserve
better now for a long time they didn't
have an alternative but now that labor
is ahead in the polls in the United
Kingdom there is an alternative they
could rid themselves to the Tory
government in Westminster and they could
rid themselves of this failing
government in Hollywood as well I am
I just want to talk a little bit more
about the alternative he said as you put
it as as labor because look in these
interviews you know we spent time
criticizing the conservatives we spent
time criticizing the SNP and it does
feel in many ways you know the stars are
aligning for a labor Victory because of
what is happening with the other parties
but I guess some of our viewers might be
thinking
it's almost like Labor's just going to
get in by default not because you're
presenting a particularly exciting
Vision or like a great big idea for the
country but just because they're a bit
Fed Up and they've got other guys look I
think the biggest most radical thing you
could do for this country right now is
focus on the country and focus on fixing
the very many problems that people yeah
everyone would agree with that but
what's the idea of them well the idea is
that you you start to fix the
fundamentals so you take an economy that
is not working for most people that
people work harder for than ever before
and you start to invest in order to
create good jobs in every part of the
country not just some so what does that
do does that mean more maybe we spend
more money no we've got we've got cast
iron fiscal rules that we won't borrow
to invest for day-to-day sending but we
will invest where there is a clear
interest for the country so the one
exception we've made to that rule is
that we will invest in the jobs of the
future and clean energy where there's
enormous potential for Britain and in
other growing Industries to rebuild our
Coastal and Industrial towns to get good
jobs back into communities that haven't
had them for a long time and money back
into people's pockets we could start
building more houses in this country
again if we weren't in hot to a
conservative party is
how many more houses with labor build
what are you doing to planning what what
what's the big idea we would streamline
the planning system to make sure that we
didn't have a block on new developments
particularly Around clean energy where
there's been uh this feels like
tinkering around the edges doesn't it
that's not tinkering around the edges
this country has been on the back foot
for 13 years because we've had a
government that is in hock to a group of
back benches who are controlling
government policy even as late as this
year with a new prime minister who said
he was going to come in and build a
fresh start they've scrapped local
housing targets house building has
fallen to its lowest level since the
second world war and we've got a housing
crisis and a growth crisis in this
country labor would turn that around or
relax so they will liberalize the
planning laws to make sure that
communities can make decisions early
about the sorts of Housing and
Development that they want will
reinstate housing targets to make sure
that houses get built and will work to
provide certainty and stability so that
people can get mortgages get on the
housing ladder with a bit of help from
the state because we don't believe that
the state should step out of the way
when the market is failing that's why
labor is the answer to the challenges
that we've got and the conservative
party can't be you know listening to you
and you look at the country and and you
talk about trust and politics you're
talking about this week about you know
the state of the NHS about creating
public services but the economy you know
inflation is still double digits and
we're talking about the big idea for
labor we're talking about communities
being involved a bit more easily in in
playing decisions earlier on I just
wonder you know you run into the
leadership as well it was pretty clear
the platform that you ran on you ran on
a platform to level up and to take power
away from London what is Kirsten's
platform we're going to sum it up what
is it so we can build a country in which
everyone has a stake and everyone has a
reward he wants to make this the best
country in the world for people to grow
grow up and grow old and at the moment
what we're seeing you mentioned the NHS
we're seeing a crown jewel public
service that was once a destination for
people all over the world who were
clamoring to come and work in our NHS
and we're now seeing us hemorrhaging
staff out to other countries because we
can't even get our act together to make
that National Health Service fit for the
future and a place that people
desperately want to work we think we
could turn that around because in every
community in this country you find
people no matter how hard-pressed who
have so much ambition for their families
their communities and their country but
what's missing is a government that has
that same level of ambition we believe
that's possible but it can only happen
where the state is prepared to get
involved roll up its sleeves and move
Heaven and Earth to make things work
instead of standing on the sidelines as
we've seen from this government over the
last 13 years holding up their hands and
saying things can't be different they
can
listen Andy there talking on path of the
labor party